hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book one of his work on anger Seneca
is going to take on a commonly made
argument about anger which basically
says that you know anger is not a great
thing but we do need it and it's the
appropriate response when it comes to
defending people who matter to us for
example family members like parents he's
going to talk about we could also think
about friends or people were responsible
for
and there's a lot of people that are
quite attracted to this notion that if
anger is appropriate in any circumstance
it's going to be defending others
defending others who need us to step in
and so you know the question is this
doesn't a good person get angry when for
example family are wronged and he takes
it on it you could say its strongest
Point particularly for an ancient
audience he says are you telling me that
a good person doesn't become angry if he
sees his father being murdered his
mother being raped and so you know
within the ancient world this is about
as Extreme as an example I suppose you
could say tortured as well right but
these are really hardcore examples if
you saw your mother being raped wouldn't
you get angry wouldn't you then defend
your mother from from that you know the
anger would have a very useful
instrumental role in you doing the right
thing and Seneca says no the anger is
actually not going to be helpful or even
needed he says that such a good person
will not become angry
but they will be their champion and
Defender and he says now this is very
interesting why are you afraid right and
he uses the word for fear there so why
are you having this emotional reaction
about anger why are you afraid that a
proper sense of devotion pietas in this
case and you know we could think of
filial piety you know piety towards
parents doing the right thing towards
their parents devotion
should lead to doing the right thing
Without Anger being needed and so this
person will be their Champion uh you
know the word there is vindicere uh in
in a different form right to vindicate
he will be their Vindicator and their
Defender and he will do so motivated by
this devotion a better thing rather than
anger and then Seneca makes another
interesting argument here he says you
know do we say the same thing about
other emotions take fear for example
fear is a natural reaction when we see
people who we care about being injured
harmed humiliated do we faint away if we
see our mother or father being attacked
no so why would you say that one
emotional reaction is bad but another
emotional reaction is is good they're
all emotional reactions which we don't
actually need all of them are equally
from seneca's point of view equally
inappropriate so he says that a good
person
is going to fulfill their duties or
translate it here follow up their
obligations their aficia this is a stoic
term that's used for Duty for
appropriate actions for what is called
upon by the person right so the good
person will actually fulfill their
duties and Seneca says the good person
will do so in the right emotional state
of mind that is undisturbed without
being you know afflicted by say anger
and undeterred they will not be stopped
even though they don't have this emotion
driving them to do so right
so he says another thing that's very
important here they will do things
worthy of a good person Bona Viro digna
so that digna there means worthy or
worthwhile and they will not do things
that are unworthy and what is the
conclusion we're supposed to draw there
acting out of anger would in fact be
unworthy indignant right something that
we don't need to do and he also follows
this up by there he consolidates this by
saying the things that are right is what
the good person is going to do right I
know that's right to defend my father
who is being killed or to bring the
matter to a proper conclusion right take
take revenge uh but not Revenge that's
motivated by anger inflict a certain
kind of punishment they'll do that
because it's right Quia aportet it's
appropriate is another way of
translating it not because
the person is pained Quia Dola literally
feels grief or pain or sadness as a
result and then feels anger because of
that pain or sadness so a good person
won't behave that way
none Seneca takes on an Aristotelian
Aristotle's best friend and
um you know successor in the school
theophrastus and he says hey
theophrastus you're wrong about anger so
what does theophrastus saying in this
you could we could say third Point
good men become angry when their friends
and family are wronged that's that's the
sign of being a good person so this is
directly opposed to seneca's own
position and Seneca is going to say
theophrastus you are appealing to the
spectators not the judge now what does
that mean so you know in a contest with
say dramas or other performances you you
want to not appeal to the crowd because
the crowd doesn't know the real you know
situation the crowd is mixed up the
crowd is going to draw bad inferences
the karate crowd is kind of
muddle-headed you want want to appeal to
the judges the people who actually know
things so when it comes to anger yeah of
course everybody does get angry or at
least most people do when somebody that
they care about is being hurt in some
way injured you know pick whatever you
want most people do behave that way
but the question is
should they
is that the right thing to do is that
the beneficial useful thing to do and so
theophoresis is actually getting things
wrong by appealing to the masses right
he says
um practically everyone reckons
righteous the feeling that they
recognize in themselves people get all
sorts of crazy ideas when they get angry
and then he says another thing as well
anger is indiscriminate
people do get angry and they get angry
over all sorts of things not just when
Mom and Dad are being insulted by some
Ruffians or something like that he goes
out and he says they do the same thing
if their hot bath is not properly
prepared they get mad right if a glass
gets broken if their shoe is spattered
with mud
what is going on here
he says it's not a sense of devotion
that stirs that kind of anger it's
weakness
it's the sort proper to children who
weep just as much whether they've lost
their parents or some hazelnuts it's a
lack of proportion of sensibility
and he he finishes up this by saying
that getting angry on behalf of one zone
literally pro-suice it's translated here
as on behalf of one's friends and family
is the mark of a weak mind so uh anime
infirmi rather than a strong or mind
devoted to duty and he says the fine and
worthy thing is to come forward in
defense and he lists a bunch of
different people here parents
children friends fellow citizens now why
should we come forward and defend these
people because it's the right thing to
do not just because we get angry you
defend them from a sense of Duty that is
leading ipso aficia du kente so the duty
itself is providing us with a reason to
defend them which is the right thing in
the situation and we don't have to get
angry in order to do this and he
concludes with a really great uh way of
of distinguishing this right he says to
do so willingly volantum we choose it
right we will to do it deliberately Yuri
contem judging right that this is the
right thing to do
prudently
providentium
and what is what does that mean being
providential sort of setting things up
in the right way planning you might even
say and how do we not do it the contrast
here not impulsively or furiously
motivated by anger we can do the right
thing without getting angry and he
concludes by saying no passion desires
Vengeance more earnestly than anger
for that very reason it's unsuited to
take revenge to Hasty and witness like
virtually every form of desire it gets
its own ways it hurries towards its goal
it screws us up it makes us less
effective less intelligent as we try to
fulfill our duties to defend those who
we have some sort of obligation to
because of our relationship so seneca's
Point here is that anything we can do
motivated by anger we can actually do
better and not just better in the sense
of more efficiently better in the moral
sense just by being motivated by Duty
and devotion